this way guys
so this is your green room
you guys can just hang out in here until
the show thanks for letting me share
your room with you kate i can't believe
we're hosting the spirit awards
oh what the hell oh they have fiji water
yes
once upon a time before you and i were
locked in room we both had tv shows and
the gig hosting the spirit awards
now we just live here
at first we cried and cried but then we
found a box of award screeners
we still haven't watched beasts of no
nation though
too heavy
[Music]
good morning please sleep
[Music]
good morning lamp good morning wardrobe
good morning tv
good morning sink
good morning egg snake guess what today
is it's a big day today is my birthday
no
it's the day of the spirit awards we got
to get ready son
i am not your son
okay this is a skin tone discrepancy i'm
pretty sure i'm older than you let me
have this
okay
mom
sure get the ones in the back
what about your teeth oh i think i'm
good
that's a good boy
do you like your little breakfast please
don't do the boys do you like your
little dairy creamer
this rug smells like garbage
oh
log rolls
oh ow
deadly crotch
deadly cries
you want to make a good luck cake yay
let's go to that part of room
here we go
i was gonna write spirit awards but i
ran out of room how did you think you
could put spirit awards on this i mean
it would take like six of these cakes to
do that i don't want to eat this cake
what do you i made frosting out of dust
from the floor yeah you know what it
looks like it you're being a baby you're
a baby you're the one who's on my nip
okay that's a good point that is
something baby's doing i can't do
anything right can i
what am i doing
we have to get out of here
i have a plan
okay there we go
yeah
so what's the plan now i don't know i
was hoping more of a plan would
materialize in my head as we were
rolling away so your plan was to roll me
up and then think of a plan oh god we
got to get out of here i'm losing it
think think i got to get to the spirit
awards
i got it oh i got it what what i got it
i got it
oh what was the code one two three four
one two three four are you kidding me
why didn't we try that i am such a
dingbat
oh
okay help me
let me out
roll yourself out i gotta pee help
seven years
i miss star wars
[Applause]
live from the santa monica pier it's the
film independent spirit awards the
biggest names in independent film are
gathering under the sun to celebrate the
most original daring and provocative
movies of the year and today the stars
and filmmakers of the bittersweet carol
the urgent spotlight the gripping beasts
of no nation as well as the poignant
room the street smart tangerine and the
groundbreaking anomalisa are all here
this is the film independent spirit
awards
and now please welcome your hosts kate
mckinnon and kumail mangiani
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
this is lovely this is wonderful oh my
goodness thank you so much welcome for
having us here
welcome welcome
welcome to the field
spirit awards the spirit awards honor
the year's best movies you've been
meaning to see
but
it's okay if you haven't seen them
because independent filmmaking isn't
about making a profit
it's not about breaking even
it's about definitely losing money
now i i i know we're not your typical
award show host you look at your typical
award show host and you go i know who
that is
instead you have ended up with us
a gay woman and a pakistani man
or as hollywood thinks of us a straight
woman and her i.t guy
tonight we're gonna do everything you
can't do with the oscars baby
we're gonna cuss
we're going to flash some nip we're
going to nominate some people who aren't
what
[Music]
tonight's nominees are more diverse than
the cover of a brochure for a liberal
arts college
while the oscar nominees are as diverse
as the actual student body of a liberal
arts college
there have been some changes to the show
since last year for example there's um
there's a new award for best onset
catering in an independent film uh the
winner and soul nominee is hummus and
baby carrots congrats to them
very good
there are so many talented people here
representing so many amazing films
from nominees like beasts of no nation
to room
to room
to spotlight
this year's nominees cover a wide
variety of difficult subjects ranging
from child abuse to even worse child
abuse
spotlight spotlight nominated for five
awards including best feature
[Applause]
but like incredible probably the best
movie about a church sex abuse scandal
that also sounds like a broadway musical
spotlight
congrats you're in the spotlight
speaking of the movie spotlight
is something the catholic church will
never do
that movie made the church look so bad
they tried to transfer it to another
parish
beasts of no nation also nominated for
five awards
this is netflix's first original movie
netflix
the company that says if you like beasts
of no nation you may also like fuller
house
[Applause]
if you haven't seen it beasts of no
nation is a story about children in
africa who would trade everything to
have a life as good as the kid in room
[Applause]
i know it seems like we're really
overdoing it on the child abuse material
now you know how we felt watching your
movies
so many big stars here tonight this is
this is amazing it's very exciting the
star of anomalisa is here
where's he oh wow
he's got some work done
i think he's something's changed it
looks good no it's good it's subtle
subtle
idris elba is nominated tonight
i truly just got lost in his eyes for a
second
that's not on script i just looked over
and there were whirlpools and i'm trying
to climb out
yes
goodness gracious let's be friends
there was a rumor last year that he was
going to be the next james bond
you know what i just don't see it a
black james bond what's next a female
ghostbuster
that would be messing up the i didn't
know that i know i could i didn't want
to do that
kate blanchett and rooney mara are here
for carol
wow
carol is uh probably the most compelling
story about someone leaving their gloves
behind since the people versus o.j
simpson
sean penn is here
but i think it's only because he saw all
these tents and figured there were some
refugees he could help
sean i'm not a refugee
um
i'm doing okay
don't need rations thank you
we got david robert mitchell in the
house nominated for best director for it
follows
thank you for making that movie that
scared the bejesus out of me after
watching it follows i couldn't have sex
with strangers for days
longest days of my life
a pigeon sat on a branch reflecting on
existence
is nominated for best international film
while its title is nominated for worst
editing
tangerine is nominated for best feature
everyone's talking about how tangerine
was shot entirely on an iphone 5s
amazing and yet nobody is talking about
how the entourage movie was written by a
2004 motorola flip phone
and directed by a can of monster energy
drink amazing
let's talk about that
give them their due a lot of you are
nominated for oscars tomorrow um i can't
say which is more important but i do
know you will never hear a movie trailer
say starring spirit award nominee brie
larson
and that's just fine with us because
we're not the oscars
we're the darn independent spirit awards
and sure we might not be the most famous
or the best looking or the most
successful
okay
let's bring out our first presenter
she won last year's spirit award for
best supporting female for her work and
boyhood please welcome to the stage the
wonderful patricia arquette
[Music]
[Applause]
hi guys
most awards shows
or no day at the beach but on pumps
but in action it's actually a pleasure
to be standing before you in this big
tent in santa monica the film
independent spirit awards shine a light
on the best and the brightest
but this is a historic moment
and i am so grateful to be here
on this day when we finally have
trans women nominated as best female
lead and best supporting leads
in both categories
so let's have a round of applause for
that
hollywood's been getting a bad rap
lately and sometimes
deservedly so but we can change that
and these films nominated today are
proof of that
okay now it is my pleasure to present
the best award for best supporting male
here are the nominees
best supporting male
kevin corrigan results i want to be able
to take a punch
i just want to be able to
take it without falling down or or uh
you know puking
paul dano love and mercy i have a song
playing over and over in my head i just
don't have the words of the melody
[Music]
idris elba beasts of no nation all of
you
that have never been listened to before
and have seen your family killed
ah you now have something that stands
for you
richard jenkins bone tomahawk well what
i'm asking is can you sit in a bathtub
full of hot water and read a
book i never tried
well i heard about people doing it all
the time but every time i try it i
ruined the book
michael shannon 99 homes only one in 100
is going to get on that ark shot
and every other poor soul's gonna drown
i'm not gonna drown
[Music]
every one of those performances
are incredible and the spirit award for
best supporting male goes to
okay
idris elba
nation
aedra's alba was inspired by director
kerry fukunaga's desire to tell a story
of war from an african perspective
[Music]
oh thank you so much um
wow look uh
uh
i i'm not here on my own right uh i
supported abraham who is um
who uh
i i i want to share this uh this award
with uh abram is an amazing talent and
never done it before so this is with you
i share this i couldn't have done it
without you um also look you know carrie
fukunaga um our director
uh
that that uh that that man that man is
truly a symbol of independent film you
know that man carried this script an
idea around for so long and everyone
said no to him and he kept it going and
that's why we're all here celebrating
this film so carrie thank you so much uh
netflix red crown my uh you are
incredible uh ted um
what's your last name again
uh ted well done man you really did uh
elevate this film to a place where no
one else could have done that my entire
team uh my agents roger and philip son
and brand joel michael sugar who
introduced me to carrie man thank you
for doing that that was incredible um
i i uh james brown does this
so i'm gonna do that thanks see you
later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
love don't come so easily
this doesn't have to end in tragedy
[Music]
[Music]
our house band tonight is a great la
group named after the principal and
ferris bueller's day off that's true
and fronted by rocker robert schwartzman
that's true let's hear it for rooney
okay guys when you see our next two
presenters you're gonna think that's a
buddy cop movie i'd pay to see please
welcome from room jacob tremblay and
from triple nine anthony mackey
[Applause]
jacob let me just start by saying you
are incredible in room wasn't he
thank you
thanks very much it's an honor to be
here celebrating the best independent
cinema but even on but an even greater
honor to be here standing beside my
all-time favorite hero wow
that's
that's so sweet of you to say man no
problem falcon
oh
oh yeah that's the superhero i play in
the movies not
me
is it
uh is it hard to fly with those heavy
metal wings
no well
jacob it's not i'm not really the falcon
i'm
anthony nice one falcon but you can't
fool me
where's red wing you're highly trained
hunting falco falcon who joins you in
battle against your enemies oh wow um
looks like we're having like a santa
claus issue up here
wait did something happen to santa
oh no no okay all right let's let's just
go to the nominees for best first
screenplay
best first screenplay
jessie andrews me and earl and the dying
girl i don't need your stupid pity it's
fine you can just go no no hey you got
it all wrong i'm not here because i pity
you i'm actually here just my mom is
making me
it's actually worse
jonas carpiniano mediterranean
[Music]
no there's not you made him up in your
head he's not real
marielle heller the diary of a teenage
girl you know you're not gonna have that
god forever man
i know that's not very
feminist of me to say but you have a
kind of power you know
you don't
john mcgarry russell harbour and nina
joseph the mend well believe it or not
my mother is from hoboken oh get out of
town she is do you still live there oh
no she's uh not with us anymore she's
not
[Music]
this is you man
and the spirit award for best first
screenplay goes to
[Music]
[Applause]
emma donahue who was born in ireland and
lives in canada adapted her screenplay
for a room from her own acclaimed 2010
novel of the same name
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
thank you
oh thank you film independent sorry i
don't need jacob's ledge
and thank you everyone who has welcomed
this ignorant newbie into the movie
business um but especially
uh element pictures and our great
director lenny abrahamson
uh
[Music]
lenny led me into the world of film like
a
mighty gandalf to my bilbo
and i couldn't have had a wiser or
kinder or funnier guide this award i'm
taking home to my beloved chris because
she's had my back over 22 years 15 books
one film and two children
and
when i was pregnant with our first child
i remember another writer a woman she
she leaned over to me and she said as
they say every every baby costs you a
book
it was a phrase i never heard before and
in my experience children do leave you
less time to write but they give you a
lot more to write about so this is
really for our children finn and duna
who inspired room the book and then room
the film and to continue to inspire me
every day i'm lucky enough to spend with
them thank you
please welcome jessica biel from a diary
of a teenage girl spirit award nominee
for best female lead bell polly
[Music]
[Applause]
in a time when there's a lot of fake
reality here's the real deal
documentaries have been have never been
more watched or more talked about than
they are right now
that's right the truth can hurt but it
can also make us laugh and think
here are six outstanding documentaries
that each in its own way brought us true
visions of our world through a powerful
and independent lens
best documentary
terror
these are all targets
that's in suspected areas making the
islam look bad you got to go
best of enemies
let's stop calling them humans goddamn
face and that'll stay plastered can they
say that
heart of a dog
give a command to a german shepherd and
he'd say right boss but give a command
to a terrier and they say is it going to
be fun
the look of silence
[Music]
you know the rewards of climbing are
huge the problem is as we know you don't
always come out of okay people die and
then you can't justify it
the russian woodpecker
[Music]
and
the independence spirit award
goes to
the look of silence
the look of silence was produced by sin
burr sorensen and directed by joshua
oppenheimer it is a companion piece to
director oppenheimer's acclaimed debut
the act of killing
both films focus on the indonesian
genocide of the mid-60s
[Applause]
oh you're perfect
thank you very very much thank you to
film independent
thanks to adi raccoon our main character
in the look of silence
and his family
who shared and who dared to share their
story with all of indonesia with us and
with the rest of the world
thanks so much
and thank you to our indonesian crew
who have to remain anonymous for their
safety
but who helped us throughout this whole
deal both with the act of killing and
the look of silence
and also bringing the film out
in indonesia and starting that whole
conversation there
thanks to
our team in in denmark final cut for
real
our co-producers in finland and norway
our f funders our financiers that are
mainly public service television and
national film institutes in scandinavia
especially in denmark where we're from
and
thank you also
so much
to all all the financiers uh the the
foundations and so on that have
supported us
and then last but not least thanks so
much to drafthouts and participants
media our fantastic distributors here in
the us
thank you
the 19th
[Applause]
[Music]
i tell this evil
[Music]
to kill someone to watch award goes to
felix thompson for king jack my name is
felix thompson and i'm the writer
director of king jack king jack is a
story about this 15 year old kid who is
essentially the last person that you
would ever give any responsibility to
like ever in life he has to look after
his little cousin for two days and it
becomes the best and worst weekend of
his life the kill summon the watch award
is kind of blowing me away a little bit
i'm still processing it but it means so
much and this grant is is just such a
wonderful opportunity to have some time
to
write the next thing
thank you so much film independent thank
you so much kiels
[Music]
our next two presenters are the stars of
the upcoming film khaleesi the movie and
by upcoming i mean i wrote it down in my
dream journal please welcome from game
of thrones in the upcoming film me
before you emilia clark and from the
sundance hit birth of a nation nate
parker
[Applause]
[Music]
so nate and i are here to answer one of
the big questions of the night
that's right and that question is
is jon snow really dead or is he alive
no no no no no we're not here we're here
to reveal the winner of best first
feature right right that's right i knew
that
nate here directed his first feature the
birth of a nation and won
the grand jury prize of sundance thank
you thank you very much amelia
that's very nice for you to mention but
we're here to talk about things that are
much more important yes yeah like jon
snow so if if he's alive just give me a
wink i won't tell her so i swear let's
um let's just show the nominees fair
enough
best first feature
the diary of a teenage girl
james white
mono soucius
mediterranea
songs my brothers taught me
and the spirit award for best first
feature goes to
the diary of a teenage girl
muriel heller miranda bailey and kerry
the diary of a teenage girl
[Music]
is
the diary of a teenage girl is based on
the graphic novel by phoebe glockner
that director marielle heller discovered
when she received the book as a
christmas gift
the style of the film's animated
sequences are based on that graphic
novel
oh my god
what a wonderful life this is
oh my gosh
um
sometimes
a project comes along that just changes
your whole life and this project was
that for me i've been working on it for
eight years and i can't believe i'm
standing up here
um i just want to take this moment to
thank all of the wonderful people who
said yes to me who probably shouldn't
have
my amazing cast
belle paoli everyone's favorite new
actress
i found her first okay i have dibs on
her
alexander skarsgard kristen wiig
chris maloney
i can't believe they all said yes to
this movie and my amazing producers who
are all here with me and carrie
miranda bailey
madeline sammett bert
michael sagel amy niakis who's not here
and my wonderful husband jorma toconi
who when i told him that we had to make
this movie before we could have a baby
i've never seen anyone work so hard to
get a movie made
and i want to thank
sony picture classics
and the sundance institute who supported
this film from the very beginning
and my whole sundance family
the wonderful other nominees who i was
up against my dear brothers and sisters
in arms and my family my parents who are
here my sister and my brother thank you
all
this year's robert altman award goes to
the director casting directors and
ensemble cast of spotlight please
welcome one of the film stars mark
ruffalo
hello
reporters
editors lawyers survivors
a portrait of boston
a portrait of journalism
a story of the team that exposed
community-wide deference to a corporate
institution with power beyond measure
and to tell the story
tom mccarthy had to assemble his own
team
an extraordinary ensemble cast
an ensemble that i felt incredibly
privileged to be part of
of course we couldn't have done it
without mike razendies
robbie robinson sasha pfeiffer matt
carroll
ben bradley jr and marty barron
a formidable group of journalists who
poured their hearts and their souls
first into breaking this story
and then over 10 years later
into showing us
how to capture their world on screen
now
i think i speak for all of us in the
ensemble when i say that i will forever
be grateful for the opportunity to have
gotten to work with both the real life
people and the actors in our cast and to
be part of one of the films nominated
tonight for best feature spotlight
[Music]
are you familiar with spotlight
we are a four-person investigative team
what i'm focused on is finding a way to
make this paper
essential to its readers i just was
immediately taken by the hook of the
story about this uh outside editor
arriving at the boston globe and on day
one informing his news team that he
wanted to go after the catholic church
the boston priests molested kids in six
different parishes over the last 30
years
the church found out about it and did
nothing you want to sue the church these
people these journalists are citizens in
the society that they report on
but that must have been incredibly
difficult for them
six percent is
90 90 priests if there were 90 of these
bastards people would know
maybe they do it costs every single one
of these people something to move this
story forward for justice you're going
to give me the names and the names of
their victims are you threatening me
they have to do the groundwork there's
no way around it and these guys are
old-timers in the best sense i want to
keep digging i am here because i care
we're going to tell this story we're
going to tell it right a lot of people
were uncomfortable with this subject you
were potentially destroying faith you
know people need the church everybody
knew something was going on and no one
did a thing we got to put an end to it
don't tell me what i got to do the thing
that is so so staggering is that the
scope of the cover-up are you telling me
that the catholic church removed legal
documents from that courthouse to
control everything you want to tell the
story but you have to prove the story
they knew and they let it happen two
kids this is a story that must be told
it could have been you it could have
been me it could have been any of us
[Music]
[Applause]
the spirit awards is honored to present
the robert altman award to spotlight
please welcome to the stage director tom
mccarthy casting directors carrie barton
and paul schnee and from the film's
ensemble cast rachel mcadams michael
keaton michael cerrell creighton brian
d'arcy james paul gilfoyle neil huff
jamie sheridan leave schreiber and mark
ruffalo
thank you very much i am tom mccarthy
the co-writer and director of the film
and mark ruffalo told me just now i was
going to speak for the team um
so uh look uh i this is probably one of
my favorite awards because uh to be
quite honest i couldn't say enough good
things
about the people i had the great uh good
fortune to work with on this stage uh
you know you putting together a film
like this is so tricky as we all know in
this room trying to tell these original
stories and for something like this
where i need a little bit more money i
needed this cast and these guys signed
on so quickly it was the easiest casting
process i've ever gone through led by
mark and michael and rachel and leave
and john and stanley and it just
trickled down the line and as a director
uh you know it's so necessary to have
the support of talent like this and to
step into roles and to step into
projects and really champion them so
from the bottom of all of our hearts i
have to say thank you to them thank you
please
and then i have to take a special moment
also to thank carrie and paul barton and
schnee who have cast all my movies these
guys are just one of the best uh two of
the best and they've done it again with
this film so gentlemen thank you very
much
and i also want to just give a special
special shout out to open road
one of the great independent studios
championing films like this
uh to tom and jason and liz and their
entire team from the very beginning
these guys were seeking us out quite
honestly before i knew who they were
they were calling and calling and just
just just told me they really wanted to
make the film we wanted to make and
they've been so supportive through this
improv entire process and quite honestly
we need companies like this right now
we're going to step up and the other
studios won't and aren't afraid to tell
these kind of stories regardless of what
they think the end game might be so to
your courage and commitment thank you
very very much
and finally and i'll get off we we you
know we're only as good uh everyone on
this stage knows we're only as good as
ours our partners in this are of course
our incredible producers uh but the
entire uh crew who in both uh boston in
toronto who were relentless in their
commitment to this so a final shout out
to them uh thank you again for being
here and thank you very much
[Music]
so
washed up
i got
sands
ladies and gentlemen please welcome ken
jong and keegan michael key
cinematographers bring the film's vision
to life with masterful shots and
exceptional use of lighting and lenses
uh the beauty of cinematography yes it's
actually my favorite of theographies
really
uh
are you forgetting pornography
[Laughter]
okay sorry i like to correct that this
is my second favorite ography
mine too
after stenography so
if you're at home right now writing down
everything that i'm saying
then um
keep up the good work really just keep
it up thank you yes
here are the nominees for best
cinematography
best cinematography
kerry joji fukunaga beasts of no nation
michael geologist it follows
[Music]
ed lachman carol
[Applause]
[Music]
read murano meadowland
[Applause]
[Music]
joshua james richards songs my brothers
taught me
[Music]
and the spirit award for best
cinematography
goes to
ed lachman for carol
ed lockman shot carol on 16 millimeter
film
to capture the texture and colors of a
faded postcard from a bygone era
his previous films with director todd
haynes
include i'm not there and far from
heaven
[Applause]
um
first i want to say awards are always
unfair if you win or if you lose
so i always feel that way
but i have to reach out
i don't stand here on my own
the vision of my director
who always inspires me
and pushes me in places i never think i
can go
thank you todd
[Applause]
the screenwriter phyllis naji who
toiled with this script for 18 years to
get it made and she created the poet the
poetic framework for our film
thank you phyllis
and to rooney mara and kate blanchette
you created the most emotional frames
with visual detail for me to capture
thank you
[Applause]
my crew
who always supports me figuratively and
literally
thank you
and last but not least
my producers
elizabeth carlson
steve woolsey
and christine vishon you were always
there for me and we say it's independent
films that just means there's not enough
money or time to make the film you want
to make but they were always there for
me and prove that we could do it thank
you
[Applause]
and in the end
i hope this film is a small voice with
an echo that says we all have the right
to love and be loved thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm so sorry to keep you waiting
so glad you found my lost gloves
at the department store where you work
and so
i wanted to thank you at the traditional
two-woman light lunch with no other
agenda whatsoever
i'm carol my name is camel i'll be
serving you guys today do you want to
order now or should we wait for your
husbands good one um
i'll have the
cream spinach over poached eggs and a
dry martini with an olive please
slow down lady i have to read your
lengthy list of 1950 specials must you
today we have a sea breeze being served
extra brainy we have a cured puree of
mashed curds that is so squeaky and
moist we have a mayonnaise encrusted
lobster white is god's face that comes
with tenderloin peas and jumbo squab and
lastly a big dead catfish
that's my personal favorite i'll stick
with the creamed spinach and parched
eggs please very good choice that is our
most disgusting meal
i'll have the same great two eleanor
roosevelt combos coming right up
something for your mouth
land this plane carol land it
thank you so much for finding my gloves
again i was so
lost without those gloves this was me
without my gloves
so
what kind of name is bellavette
it's jack jack
what a coinky tank
cause i was trying to check you out at
the checkout counter check please oh i'm
just putting your food down right now
you already want to check it is an
expression kumail it was part of the
seduction
i mean glove lunch
and what's your first name therese
durangs
what a funny little name
flung out of space
i think i just came down with therese
syndrome
you're beautiful
you know i have a funny little name too
of camal people think it's indian but
actually i'm pakistani but it's a really
new country because we're still in the
1950s camille i am mid-seduction would
you get out of here cause i'm rounding
third and i'm heading home and yes i am
talking about softball
do you
like to play softball tourist
i do
i'm confused who are you seducing
think about it
i don't
oh
you're trying to seduce me
i'm working a double and i i work till
10 30 and i'm kind of seeing this girl
we haven't had the talk yet but things
are sort of heading into specific
directions so i'm a freaking lesbian
okay and she's about to be two if you
would just get the hell out of here whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
what
it's the 1950s you know you're blowing
my mind this is not that kind of place
camille it is that kind of place you
work at a lesbian restaurant the place
is called lezzies for crying out loud
look at your name deck
oh i thought it said leslie's
look around there are a lot of
clandestine glove lunches happening here
[Music]
hey look the indian kid finally figured
it out whose eggs do i got to poach to
get a refill on my creamed spinach
i can't wait for the 50s to be over you
can't hey blondie why don't you come
join us yeah you got two sure things
sitting right here three if you count my
hat come on carol give a dog a ball
they make a good point
why because you're maybe like not there
yet i barely even know what to order for
lunch
i'm going to
pop over there and
get what's mama's
thank you so much for lunch and for the
gloves
[Applause]
[Music]
i like what you wear and i like how you
move
if i was
staring alone
[Music]
i love relaxing by the beach listening
to the chirping seagulls and the
crashing waves okay we don't get to do
this anymore
you do not look relaxed
i'm not i'm not supposed to be out here
i have so many moles i'm at what my
dermatologist calls the tipping point
come on half an hour won't kill you it
will
i'm scottish our only natural predator
is the sun
i'm pakistani our only natural predator
is donald trump
i feel a mold coming out i gotta go wait
wait wait we have to introduce the next
presenter come on all right all right
please welcome spirit award nominee from
anomalisa jennifer jason lee
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
charlie kaufman's anomalisa
it was originally conceived as a radio
play which we performed for two nights
at royce hall it was fantastic but
bittersweet because it was never
recorded and after two nights it was
done
so it was a complete thrill to get a
call from charlie nearly a decade later
asking us to participate in a new
incarnation
a stop-motion animated movie it ended up
being a crazy and perfect marriage
anomalisa seems to unfold in real time
it's a film where you forget altogether
that you're watching puppets
true to the independent spirit when they
ran out of money rosa tran our producer
raised more on kickstarter
charlie and his gifted gifted
co-director duke johnson made a movie
that breaks the rules in such
a profound way that when we watch
anomalisa it's like seeing a wholly new
art form at times heartbreaking at times
painfully intimate the film lays bare
and ex the extraordinary awkwardness of
human interaction
anomalies exposes our isolation and our
yearning for connection
the longing to be seen
and the need to be loved
here is a clip from the extraordinary
and singularly beautiful anomalisa
hi
oh my god
it's you hi i'm sorry to bother you no
no not at all
do you want to come in
um i was just looking for someone uh i i
think i've got the wrong oh
it's mr stone michael stone really
oh my god
oh my god
hello
oh do i look awful i was just taking my
makeup off oh my god oh don't don't look
at me hello
no
you look lovely
i can't believe you're in our room
we came here from akron just to hear you
speak
oh my god please don't look at me well
i'm certainly very flattered you can
look at me emily
[Applause]
please welcome the star of love and
mercy paul dano and from vinyl juno
temple
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the pioneering indie filmmaker john
cassavetes once said i won't call my
work entertainment it's exploring
because he worked by his own rules
cassavetes often did his exploring with
his wife jenna rollins and some close
friends on a very tight budget and
that's why the john cassavetes award is
presented to the creative team of a film
budgeted at less than five hundred
thousand dollars
these are this year's nominees
the john cassavetes award
advantageous
christmas again
heaven knows what
krisha out of my hand
[Applause]
okay and the john cassavetes award goes
to
krisha
krisha was shot in nine days at director
trey edward schultz's parents house and
stars many members of his own family
including his aunt krisha edwards as the
title role
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh uh thank you guys
we weren't expecting this so i don't
really know what to say um we made this
film in nine days at my mom's house and
it stars my aunt
and uh
i want to thank my girlfriend who's at
home watching this right now i love you
chase one of the nominated producers who
couldn't be here and gave a seat to my
mother so she could be here um a24 for
being a brave enough distributor to put
this film out it stars a six-year-old
woman that's not famous but they're
brave enough to put it out and it comes
out next month so please go see it um
the other nominees your films are
beautiful they're brilliant
uh i don't know what else to say
john cassavetes is a hero of mine he's a
genius and a pioneer
it's an honor to win an award for him
and uh everyone else that worked on this
movie this was a family affair it was
nothing but family and friends it was
the most beautiful experience of my life
and this is a beautiful way to end it
it's incredible thank you guys
sometimes i say the wrong things
[Music]
i'm stuck in these boots
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our next presenter made her astonishing
feature film debut in tangerine please
welcome spirit award nominee for best
supporting female
maya taylor
[Applause]
tangerine my first and best movie yet is
a comedy that tells that classic
hollywood tale about a transgender sex
worker who discovers that her boyfriend
slash pimp has been cheating on her
okay maybe that's not the old classic
hollywood but
damn straight it is sure hollywood today
especially right near the corner
yeah especially right near the corner of
highland and santa monica where our very
colorful story is centered even though
tangerine features some characters that
might not have
been on screen before
and
was shot entirely on an iphone that was
modified of course it's still a very
funny and moving film about a subject
that is timeless and for everyone
friendship
friends let's take a short trip across
town to the gritty streets of hollywood
and all take a little bite of tangerine
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i've been great i got some good news to
tell you i'm what i've been keeping a
secret about me and chester
girl
i know what it is
you're breaking up with him thank
god because honey for him to be cheating
on you like that wait wait what
um
you you didn't know
[Music]
a nominee tonight as best male lead for
his performance in the end of the tour
jason siegel
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it starts with an idea and then a writer
or two alone in a room with a blank
piece of paper
and questions is this a story worth
telling will anyone care
am i good enough to write this
for our nominees tonight the answer was
a resounding yes
here are the nominees for best
screenplay
best screenplay
charlie kaufman anomalisa
donald margulies the end of the tour tom
mccarthy and josh singer spotlight
phyllis naji carol s craig zoller bone
tomahawk
and the award goes to
tom mccarthy and josh singer for
spotlight
spotlight is tom mccarthy and josh
singer's first collaboration and each
saw the screenplay as an opportunity to
shine a light on the importance of local
journalism and long-term investigative
reporting
[Applause]
hi i'm tom mccarthy this is josh singer
thank you for this amazing award
i came here with my first film the
station agent and this place has always
been a really special environment so uh
it's just great to be back um
there's so many other people to thank
but i think specifically uh i'll let
josh speak in a second and do some
thinking too but we want to just single
out uh some of the real life reporters
who are here who gave so much of their
time and energy this story so they're
right over here if you guys could stand
sasha pfeiffer robbie robinson mike
cresendes
marty barron ben bradley jr matt carroll
[Applause]
now
uh every every bit of inspiration from
their movie was really taken from their
hard work it really guided us
aesthetically in so many ways so we are
forever indebted and thank you to this
and to my lovely wife wendy who's here
tonight thank you
i just said we have one more person with
us tonight phil saviano who is a
survivor and one of the survivors who
helped break the story phil if you want
to stand up
and my lovely wife laura dave
thank you
[Music]
shaking
[Music]
[Applause]
the truer than fiction award goes to
elizabeth chai vassar haley for
incorruptible
my name is chai vassarelli i directed
and produced incorruptible incorruptable
looks at the 2012 senegalese
presidential elections where the
president changed the constitution to
allow for a third term
the film asked questions about freedom
and democracy the truth and fiction
award for incorruptable means a hell of
a lot to me it was a film that kind of
had to be made this grant is really
important and helped shining a light on
the story and i'm really grateful
thank you film independent for the truth
and fiction award
we all know the internet is great for
things like leaving vindictive
restaurant reviews and sending pictures
of your genitals or for googling
pictures of a dress
while you're hosting an awards show but
did you know
it's also helping fun independent movies
tonight anomalisa is the first best
feature nominee to be backed by
kickstarter
and the perks were great
perks were great for 50 bucks you got a
t-shirt and the highest backer donated
so much money that her reward was a
ticket to the spirit awards where is she
she
where is she oh there she is connie
plimpton everyone i ain't doing
hey
jen you want some ham i got plenty of
loose ham okay i'll have more for me
okay happy to be here what i expected
okay i'm having a time of my life over
here with jericho
yeah i can't believe her one of you is
having a great time no ham maybe she's a
vegetarian i don't know
i think there are a few reasons why she
doesn't want to dip into that ham connie
all right
so what compelled you to give so much
money to this project i just i love
these weird art films so much i had to
give
i i love any movie where i'm the only
person in the theater because it's
easier to sneak in my therapy birds that
way
okay i have so many questions but i'm
not gonna ask any of them you could stop
eating while i'm talk okay all right or
keep going so did you uh did you like
anomalisa oh yeah oh
really great good job charlie i love the
music yeah oh you mean when jennifer
jason lee sang that cindy loper song
that was so so intimate i prefer true
colors but that was more of like a
ballady vibe
yeah buddy that's not ringing a bell
i might have been in the can for that
part
but i thought the kid who played dr dre
was so dope
okay i i i think you're talking about
straight out of compton
no man anomalisa
the paul giamatti movie about the nwa
what's the n stand for by the way and
let me know at the table
i'm not gonna don't worry about what
that is um
you're definitely talking about straight
out of compton
shoot
all right all right i must have gone in
the wrong theater
wouldn't be the first time
wait so you gave thirty thousand dollars
to anomalisa
watched straight out of compton and
we're just fine with that
i'm gonna level with you camille i
wasn't really in this for the movie okay
i wanted a day drink in santa monica and
meet paul dannell
where is that hunky sad-eyed sex machine
i'm going to give that guy a bubble bath
where is he okay that's unsettlingly
specific he's right behind you
there he is second buddy where is he oh
freaking oh no run paul daniel run
yeah go go oh no
oh
that's i just called daryl okay and i
think a bunch of ham did as well
[Applause]
all right i'm going to go die now i
guess
[Applause]
another lisa
all right great did not think that's how
that was going to end
all right let's move on to our next
award
here to present the prize for best
international
best international film
i'm trying to compose myself you know
him from mr robot and you can see her in
the upcoming movie knight of cups please
welcome rami malik and freda pinto
[Applause]
we're here to present the award for the
best international film
these incredible features showcase the
brilliant artistry of our colleagues
from all across the globe
every nominated film was shot outside
the united states
unlike america's films which are shot
right here and home
in vancouver
here are the nominees for best
international film
[Applause]
best international film
embrace of the serpent
girl hood
mustang
a pigeon sat on a branch reflecting on
existence
son of saul
[Applause]
all right all right
and the spirit award for best
international film goes to son of saul
laszlo nemes
director and co-writer lazlo nemes's
unyielding vision of the holocaust made
it nearly impossible to secure funding
to make the film
but the country of hungary's film fund
saw son of saul's importance and
ultimately financed the production
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
thank you so much i really appreciate it
makes me very happy
um
i want to share this award with my crew
and
and cast
that was actually an international cast
and i don't see them but
[Music]
my main actor gesari
my cinematographer mata shaddy
and
and two producers gabaran and gabor
shivers
[Applause]
thank you so much it means a lot to us
uh that
you know the
the language of film the grammar film
is not something you know
that uh
that stopped evolving
and we
we want to explore and
i take it as an encouragement thank you
very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
baby
were you ever happy
[Music]
you know him as the commandant from
beasts of no nation but i know him as my
future best friend
please welcome spirit award winner
tonight for best supporting male idris
elba
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay um
teleprompter
we all here today because we want to
just get drunk and watch it but no
that's not what it says go back
we're all here today because there are
some stories
that need to be told and yet can only
reach the screen if someone has the
talent the passion and the fearless
independence to put them out there
against all odds now beast of donation
is one of those stories um the film
shows the harrowing journey of one young
west african man called agu i should say
man's boy
who captured and systematically
transformed into a child soldier and
killer
our remarkable director kari yoshi
fukunaga
was uh
was given uzo israeli's novel by a
friend in a peace corps
and so began his long journey to bring
our world this powerful tale of war and
peace
this is the story of a good boy
from a good family who is forced to
confront the all-too-thin line between
innocence and evil
this is beast of no nation
i'll go you're going to kill this man
please ah i'm supposed to be fixing
i'm going to kill him today don't be a
soldier lisa
i'm an engineering student from the
university of mechanic
i'm supposed to be fixing the bridges
not being shut off ah
shut your mouse first be something for
this guy
ah why not be my check that's too big
so when you are chopping wood lift up
high eye up high uh-huh
then when you are ready you calm down
soon
to present our next award last year's
best supporting male spirit award winner
for whiplash jk simmons
[Applause]
thanks
my first movie
okay it was a tv movie uh i played
patrolmen in park i'm sure you remember
it
it
came out 30 years ago this year and last
year i won
my first independent spirit award as
best supporting male
thank you
not that i'm fishing it says that really
it does
which is proof of course that good
things can come to those who wait
and wait and wait and
and work and work and uh
and now it is my distinct privilege to
hand out an acting trophy to one of
these very extraordinary actresses the
deserving nominees for best supporting
female
[Music]
best supporting female
robin bartlett age
[Music]
marin ireland glass chin i don't know if
i can be your girl anymore
i'll always be your friend but
i gotta look out for myself a little bit
you know
jennifer jason lee anomalisa i feel like
an anomaly
before i used to know there was a word
for it it made me
feel bad to be different
now i kind of like it sometimes
i mean not a lot but sometimes cynthia
nixon james white
we feel good things
way up here
but we feel bad things
way
way
way down there
maya taylor tangerine out here it is all
about our hustle and that's it he owes
me money
why does he owe you money we made a
business transaction
[Music]
and the spirit award for best supporting
female goes to
maya taylor
this is maya taylor's first film and
this is the first major film award ever
given to a transgender actress
oh
first of all no one tells you how
nervous you're going to be
when you're up against like other big
actors for an award you know there's so
many things that go through your head
you know am i going to trip on this long
ass dress getting up here
you know am i going to plant my face in
the ground
there's so much
so
i have had a long journey through my
2015 because
i had come from almost nothing and then
got this role in this movie and my life
has just did a total 360.
i'm so out of breath i feel fat
but um
um
i met this wonderful director and writer
shawn baker
and chris pragos
sean baker and chris bergash said
we're gonna film this movie on iphones
yeah
the first thing i thought is
this movie ain't gonna be shit
but it turned out to be amazing and you
know i started meeting this amazing team
with darren and xiting our producers
mark and j dupla
you know i'm marcus and carrie cox my
co-stars katana kiki rodriguez james
branson mickey o'hagan
and
the worst one of them all
my manager alan mundell which i love i
love him i love him i love him he gets
on my nerves but i love him i love it
yeah
um joanne wiles um
magnolia
who did our distribution i love you
ariane rocky she makes my life so much
easier
[Applause]
my mother
and my partner james i love you you're
my everything and most of all thank god
you know
so what i want to leave with you guys
today is
there is transgender talent there's very
beautiful transgender talent so
you better get out there and put it in
your next movie
thank you guys so much i love you all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but now you play this game
[Music]
our next two presenters are from carol
the biopic about the inventor of gaydar
please welcome spirit award nominees for
best female lead oh my god kate
blanchett and rooney mara
[Applause]
[Music]
carol aired rejects the societal norms
for women in the 1950s that of wife and
mother to reconcile her desire for
another woman
therese bellivet a young store clerk
unwise to matters of the heart embarks
on a journey of self-discovery and
sexual curiosity that will define her
life forever in phyllis nash's
beautifully
crafted adaptation of patricia
highsmith's novel carol and teresa's
dangerous exploration of outlawed love
is directed by the visionary genius and
truly independent spirit todd haynes
it's a cinematic experience reminiscent
of the old classics when the silent
moments between and the spaces between
the lines were as equally powerful as
the words on the teleprompter
paige
through their shifting points of view
you witnessed carolyn therese's intense
longing to become one and the
inescapable torment that ultimately
pulls them apart
it's a complex film with the simplest
truth
love is love
here is carol
i'm going away for a while
when
where
whoever my car will take me
west
soon
and i thought
perhaps you might like to come with me
would you
yes
yes i would
please welcome actor director and
producer jason bateman
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
the remarkable directors in this next
category i'll share three crucial things
first a fierce dedication to creative
excellence
second the guts to overcome every
obstacle against tremendous odds and
finally
the extremely attractive even adorable
head shot of me i handed out to each of
them just moments ago i cannot wait to
work with with each and every one of
them it's going to be dynamite
these are the nominees for best director
sean baker for
tangerine
shawn baker for vividly bringing us life
on the streets of hollywood in tangerine
kerry joji fukunaga for exploring africa
and the very human costs of war for one
child and one child soldier and beast of
no nation
todd haynes
todd haynes for capturing the
complexities of love and all the
obstacles that confront two very
different women in carol
duke johnson and charlie kaufman for
creating a haunting way to see and hear
the human experience in anomalisa
tom mccarthy for capturing all the drama
of journalists pursuing a story of great
consequence in spotlight
and david robert mitchell for bringing a
new shape-shifting energy and modern
buzz to the horror genre in it follows
and the spirit award for best director
goes to tom mccarthy spotlight
director tom mccarthy is also a prolific
actor but he won his very first film
independent spirit award in 2004 for
directing his first feature the station
master
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you again i just want to quickly
thank um uh nicole rocklin and bly faust
who would not take no for an answer
uh they came to me with this story and
the first time and i said no and then
they came back and thankfully i said yes
thank you and to steve golden and
michael sugar our two other producers
for their perseverance
and for to michael biederman our
incredible line producer who like make
just made believe this movie was
happening until it was actually
happening so uh i really want to thank
them and of course to the rest of my
team and everybody else this is such an
incredible uh uh bounty of riches and to
my fellow nominees you're all so
impressive todd specifically your movies
have inspired me for a long time sir
wherever you are i salute you and to the
rest of you keep making movies it's
really inspirational thank you all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the psja producers award goes to
mel eslin my name is mel eslin and i am
the producer of lamb there were many
many challenges on lambs we had an
eleven-year-old girl we were shooting on
a ranch in the middle of nowhere then
our location flooded in the beginning of
mosquito summer with 15 people you know
independent film is about the trials and
the tribulations of having limited
resources and but also trying to stay
sustainable and make really really great
films and tell really good stories the
film independent spirit awards recognize
the true meaning of independent film
in
such a way that i feel like no other
awards do
thank you film independent thank you
piaget
as you can see the spirit awards are
just steps from the ocean and when you
walk out of the big tent you can hang
with our sponsors and vips at the only
backstage area where you could get
pecked to death by a seagull one tried
to steal my clutch earlier so i escaped
into the american airlines tent where i
successfully upgraded to a live flat
seat for my flight home thank you
[Applause]
now to present the award for best male
lead please welcome the honorary chair
of film independent jessica chastain
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our next spirit award is for best male
lead
jeff bridges who's won this award twice
once said a large part of acting is just
pretending you get to work with these
other great make believers all make and
believe as hard as they can
so let's all show some spirit and hear
it for five truly awesome make believers
this year's excellent nominees
best male lead
christopher abbott james white no one
tells me anything she doesn't tell me
anything what am i supposed to do what
am i supposed to do
abraham at all
[Applause]
mississippi grind
jason siegel the end of the tour as the
internet grows in the next 10 15 years
and virtual reality pornography becomes
a reality
we're gonna have to develop some real
machinery inside our guts
to turn off pure unalloyed pleasure or i
don't know about you i'm gonna have to
leave the planet
on mediterranean
[Applause]
[Music]
and the spirit award for best male lead
goes to
abraham
[Applause]
this is abraham mata's first ever
on-screen performance he was a young
street vendor in africa when director
carrie fukanaga cast him in the role of
a west african child soldier
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you
thank you today uh thank you to the film
independent for this award first of all
i want to say thank you to ted and
everyone who worked on the movie
and thank you to the producers amy
daniela rivera and dan crown and a
special thank you to kerry you know for
letting me play this role thank you and
thank you to my co-stars iris alba and
the cast and thank you to my agent
sandra and thank you to zoe and malcolm
for helping me
on set and thank you to
the costume designer and everyone if i
forgot thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our next presenter has more credits than
i have cats and that's really saying
something his performance last year in
birdman earned him a spirit award
here to present the award for best
female lead please welcome michael kaden
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah sure
did you take my ham from before thanks
okay
thank
you this is very good ham
there was a guy in the street uh wearing
a pirate hat and no pants gave it to me
it's awfully good
one year ago
i was so damn honored to stand on the
stage
see that's a problem with doing props
now i guess well
i was very honored to stand on this
stage and accept the spirit award for
best best male lead actor
which as a matter of fact i lovingly
polished a little earlier today
and in fact i took a selfie just to
prove it
a little alteration i made on it
[Applause]
clearly
as a very satisfying moment in my life
and to be honest with you this right now
isn't nearly as good but
it's still pretty damn cool to be up
here and i get to share this stage just
for this moment with one of any of these
five excellent nominees the remarkable
actresses
nominated for best female lead
best female lead
kate blanchette carol you take it or
leave it
but if you leave it
we go to court
and if we go to court
it'll get ugly
and we're not ugly people ouch brie
larson room he was trying to trick me
okay
there wasn't a dog old neck stole me i
want a different story no this is the
story that you get
belle paoli the diary of a teenage girl
i don't want to go to school ever again
nobody loves me
maybe i should kill myself nah
alienation is good for your art katana
kiki rodriguez tangerine you must
promise me that there's not gonna be any
drama i promise i promise
look at me in my eyes and promise i
promise you'll drama alexandra
come on
rooney mara carol and it's selfish
because
because i just take everything and i
don't know anything and i don't know
what i want how could i when all i ever
do is say yes to everything
[Music]
wow
by the way jason trembley's 47 years old
just like to keep things in perspective
and
and the spirit award for best female
lead goes to
brie larson
brie larson was nominated for a spirit
award in 2013
as best female lead for her role in
short term 12. she consulted a trauma
expert and followed a strict diet
regimen to create her powerful
performance in room
[Music]
thank you
hello
i'm so excited to be with all of you
because
independent film is the best
it is what helped me grow up it's what
helped me make me see what a real woman
was what real love looked like what
messiness of life looks like and i'm so
excited to be in a room with such brave
filmmakers
i got room because of another
independent film i did that i was i was
nominated here for called short term 12.
and
and
it really has taken me a long time to
get to this point but i'm so proud of
the harder road i've taken and the bold
choices that i've taken and the
incredibly inspiring people that i have
worked with from financiers to directors
to editors actors everyone that is part
of the independent film community you
mean so much to me and i am so grateful
to be here and to be a representative of
that
um i would personally like to thank
first our editor nathan
because i know my performance would not
be very good without your hand
you see things that nobody else will
thank you for making me look good
i'd also like to thank our director
lenny
our incredible
mom uh our screenwriter the woman who
created this world emma
um
our dp danny cohen production designer
ethan tobin the incredible a24 who has
led us through this incredible journey
that i am so grateful for i have never
seen a movie through like this and i am
so excited and happy to have worked with
you on this thank you for your support
thank you to my parents for supporting
me through everything even sometimes
financially because as we know
independent films don't pay
and um
to my incredible boyfriend alex
thank you i love you
our cast
my spirit animal jacob trombley who is
45 years old 47
it's hard to tell
um thank you thank you very much have a
great night
[Applause]
[Music]
to pretend no i don't want to
[Music]
save you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome sean
penn
[Applause]
my friend dennis hopper who helped give
birth to independent film with easy
rider nearly 50 years ago
once said art is a bad word in hollywood
you use art too many times and they'll
show you the elevator
and then your name is taken off the
parking lot
that's not the case here at the spirit
awards where art is welcome inside the
big tent
and in the parking lot too
here are the nominees for best feature
film
anomalisa
beasts of no nation
carol
spotlight
and tangerine
and the spirit award for best feature
goes to
spotlight
come on
[Applause]
girl
what you're what you're about to see is
a reminder that it takes a village to
make a movie so
thank you film independent we are so
honored to be here
um
we have to shout out to participant
media who was with us from the beginning
participant
is all over all these awards tonight so
they deserve to be congratulated for
their courage uh and their tenacity in
making quality independent film and some
good studio ones too
um
to our incredible cast our writer
writers josh and tom and tom's vision as
a filmmaker which is extraordinary and
anyone who has a chance to work with him
would be so lucky
to our our personal inspirations and our
heroes
the reporters and editors of the boston
globe spotlight team
i've been personally very blessed to be
involved with so many films that have
been honored in one way or another by
this group and others
and it is very rare to be able to make a
film that impacts the world as
significantly as this one has and by
honoring it you are making more people
aware of it and the more people that are
aware of it the more lives can be spared
from abuse so thank you for this honor
on behalf of all of us
cheers
all right thanks for watching the spirit
awards guys that's it no reason to watch
the oscars tomorrow this probably
re-airs tomorrow so just watch it again
good night
[Applause]
film independent would like to thank its
premier sponsors official luxury jewelry
and watch partner piaget
official financial services partner bank
of america bank of america life's better
when we're connected official beer
sponsor heineken heineken open your
world
official airline partner american
airlines american airlines the
entertainment industry's preferred
airline official luxury automotive
partner jaguar jaguar the art of
performance our broadcaster ifc
ifc always on slightly off
and a special thanks to briar's gelato
indulgences ethan vodka keels since 1851
fiji water and presque isle wine
the spirit awards are produced by film
independent film independence mission is
to champion creative independence and
visual storytelling and support a
community of artists who embody
diversity innovation and uniqueness of
vision
film independent members vote to decide
the winners of the spirit awards learn
more about membership and join at
filmindependent.org
membership
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sometimes you gotta just get up and run
away we burn a little brighter
we fly a little higher
we move a little faster
closer to disaster my
[Music]
a little
[Music]
longer a little stronger
[Music]
find a way